hello everyone my name's emily and this
is some sub a channel all about survival
in the online jungle i want to
understand why the hype around nfts is
more and more reminiscent of a stock
bubble today we'll talk about whether
it's still possible to make money on
non-fundable tokens and when the big
bang will happen
[Music]
so this is alex chu
in 2005 he was just a struggling student
alex lived with his parents in a small
house in wiltshire england and was
puzzling over where to find the money to
fund his studies at nottingham
university he tried a number of ideas
including organising meetings of
beatboxers a personal hobby of his and
coming up with a pouch for used chewing
gum but all of these undertakings were
far from successful however one night an
idea came to him that was amazing in its
simplicity he spent his last 50 pounds
to buy a catchy domain name and made a
one-page website in two days
with the help of this site just four
months later alex earned his first 1
million dollars
but do you know what he was selling on
this site pixels
colored dots on the screen
the whole site is a picture of a
thousand by one thousand pixels
you could buy a pixel for as little as a
dollar a piece
but there were two conditions
firstly the value of the transaction
could not be less than a hundred dollars
and secondly
no porn
now after paying for your pixels you
could post any image on the site and add
a link to your own website
uploaded images and links remained yours
forever
it's really a very simple idea now the
project caused quite a stir
alex sold the last 1000 pixels on new
year's eve on ebay they went for 39 000
almost four times more expensive than
the ordinary pixels but so much money
appearing out of thin air played
something of a cruel joke on alex he
dropped out of school and moved to
london and there together with his new
friends alex tried to repeat the success
of his first site
he launched a series of projects with
similar mechanics
now have you ever heard about one
million people pixelato pop jam
well
unsurprisingly no you haven't they
failed what was called the first time
round turned into an unsuccessful copy
of a once original idea
people willing to participate in these
kinds of projects were few and far
between
now several years later the internet
blew up another project in which you
were offered to buy a unique sequence of
numbers for real money of course such a
proposal would hardly become popular if
it hadn't been backed up by an unusual
combination of technology and emotion
i'm talking about cryptokitties
from the user's point of view this is a
collectible game in which you buy a
digital kitten
now it isn't able to meow but it has a
dozen special characteristics the shape
of the tail the eyes the colour and
length of fur some of the cats are
smiling some of them aren't
now the mechanism of the service
guarantees that you will be the owner of
a unique and inimitable pet
there's no such thing as twins in this
digital feline world but if you have two
kittens then they can become parents of
other kittens and their parents digital
genes will be transferred to them
now the more rare characteristics a pet
has the higher its value
it's very similar to pokemon only
there's no battles involved so canadian
programmers immediately provided an
auction service for the resell of
kittens
at the end of 2017 riding on the wave of
popularity their cost skyrocketed
if the first cryptokitties were sold for
a few dollars then after a few months
the cost of these rare animals had
climbed as high as a hundred and forty
thousand dollars for comparison let's
consider that the most expensive real
cat in history at bengal named kato cost
the owner a hundred thousand less at
only forty one thousand four hundred and
thirty five dollars
everyone everywhere was talking about
kittens
in a few months the amount of kitties
being traded grew and a flood of new
users joined the game
they brought the developers about 20
million and then they crashed the system
there were so many people that wanted to
own a kitten that actually in december
2017 their transactions completely
overwhelmed the capacities of the
ethereum platform
now each cat was just a token tied to
the ether
user transactions exceeded 15 of the
total turnover and the system was
unprepared for this cryptocurrency
trading was suspended and users learnt
their first lesson about cryptocurrency
trading all transactions take place
without any guarantees
this is not stock trading or playing
around with exchange rates
legislation on working with
cryptographic values whether we're
talking about coins or tokens in
principle didn't exist yet
purchases of any cryptocurrency from the
point of view of the law were akin to an
exchange of real money for
notes from monopoly it's therefore
unsurprising that the interesting
cryptokitties swiftly waned but there
are still stories online about how the
first users successfully made money from
the resale of these rare animals now
this prompted programmers to begin to
refine crypto platforms the owners of
the ethereum platform increased
commissions for such transactions and
businessmen became seriously interested
in the erc721 protocol which describes
nfts in detail in the very same year
2017 thousands of copycat projects and
original platforms sprung up
most of them have long been forgotten
but you've probably heard about a couple
of them for example crypto punk or board
ape york club which are still attracting
new buyers
[Music]
we know that you guys love to hear
stories about money laundering and i've
got some really exciting news for you
tony head of legal at some sub has
recently done a new interview with raj
karangara an experienced money
laundering reporting officer from london
now raj advises numerous financial
companies in areas such as crypto forex
and online payments
raj has real hands-on experience as an
mlro in these rapidly emerging
industries
in this video tony discusses a
risk-based approach in crypto
transactions which tools to use as well
as detecting and reporting suspicious
transactions cash is still king when it
comes to laundering crypto crypto's
getting a bad name because it's the
young kid on the block
sound interesting
then i highly recommend checking out our
new channel some sub for experts
[Music]
now my colleague bradley spoke about the
beginning of the second wave of interest
in crypto tokens more than a year ago
and since then
everything has happened right in front
of us for a world that was previously
only interesting to a very small
audience a lot of money has come into
the world of digital art
well no
not just a lot of money but big money
huge money
and you can be the judge of this
yourself
this collage of works by mike winkelmann
was sold at auction at christie's for 69
million dollars
it used to be the works of picasso van
gogh and modigliani that fetched a high
price at auction
now it's a link to a digital painting
by the way this point is one that is
overlooked by many
by buying an nft token you're not buying
the rights to an image or words or music
you're just buying a line in the
database
it uniquely matches two combinations of
characters your id and the token
description
it can be a text characteristics of a
kitten or a link to a picture but
nothing more
so why do people pay such vast sums of
money for them
well there are three main categories of
buyers the first are investors
their goals are clear buy an inexpensive
good in a growing market it's not
important exactly what it's just that
the price will increase consistently
and then sell it for more money than
they bought it for
from this perspective the item should
have a mechanism for transfer and the
potential number of buyers
now there are no problems with the
transmission mechanisms of nfts but no
one can guarantee the availability of
buyers this is the first tweet ever
posted on twitter jack dorsey wrote in
march 2006 when he was testing the
platform
in 2021 dorsey generated an nft using
the link for it and sold it as part of a
charity auction for almost three million
dollars now it was bought by cena estavi
who heads a malaysian startup astavi
didn't hide that he bought the nft for
investment purposes and by april this
very same token came up for auction
again estabi planned to get at least 50
million for it
but he was faced with a harsh reality
the maximum bid was 2.2 ether
or in dollars 6 856
a rather dubious investment isn't it
well i think we'll see more and more of
such examples every day the second
category of buyers are those that use
nfts for dirty financial schemes
now i don't want to repeat topics we've
already discussed so just take a look at
this graph
the green line shows the number of
unique sellers on the nft market the red
line shows the number of unique buyers
now if you're to trust your own eyes
then the number of sellers is constantly
equal to the number of buyers
can you imagine if in the real world
individual shops were built for each of
us
is this even possible
but it's not infrequent that aml experts
come across something like this when
investigating schemes for cashing money
to legalize large amounts of money
criminals use schemes that involve
one-day firms
they're created for one transaction and
then disappear
and we can see something similar in
action with nfts the scheme is pretty
simple you buy cryptocurrency for legal
money and then spend it on an item from
a popular nft collection
a few months later you just have to buy
the necessary amount of cryptocurrency
using dirty money and anonymously
purchase the nft from yourself
and that's it the transaction is open
legal and is outside the traditional
framework of regulations in february the
u.s treasury department published a
study on how works of art are used in
money laundering schemes
now a special place in it was given to
countering the legalization of income
with the help of nfts
it seems that we're waiting on a serious
tightening of legislation in the field
of control of such operations but we
still have one more group of buyers to
discuss
ordinary people
the first two categories by their
actions can inflate the prices of nft
items up to the skies
and such stories of course are a tasty
morsel for any journalist or blogger
it's no wonder we hear about them
everywhere
but
honestly have you never had the desire
to try and make money using nfts
if you buy an inexpensive nft
and suddenly it might double in value
and now imagine that you can influence
its value by some relatively effortless
actions
i'm not talking about buying computer
for mining that's obviously difficult
and expensive
but for example something as simple as
visiting a website regularly or doing
some exercise for example walking as was
the case with pokemon go
then the time you put into it will at
the same time be productive now this
definitely has some pretty interesting
applications doesn't it
the founders of the australian startup
step in thought the same
they have combined the concept of move
to earn and collectible auctions from
cryptokitties to start earning
cryptocurrency this time at solana
you'll have to buy an nft of virtual
sneakers
now these sneakers have unique
characteristics and these
characteristics affect earnings
they determine the time of your paid
workout and the type of activity walking
jogging or running if you want to earn
more buy more expensive sneakers
a special calculator helps you to
calculate your balance
you've got to agree it's very similar to
creating a character in some rpg apart
from that everything is pretty simple
walk or run earn virtual currency which
can be used for improving or repairing
your sneakers buy a new pair or multiply
already purchased ones yes in the world
of steppen sneakers are able to
reproduce now the only slightly
confusing thing is that in addition to
solana two internal currencies are used
in the system
i reckon that this startup will make an
appearance on our news feeds again soon
right now it's working in a closed
format so to become a participant in the
project you need an invitation and these
are issued by other players and the
owners of steppen while the number of
invitations is at the moment strictly
limited the project is somewhat similar
to that of an exclusive fitness club but
already there is a whole market for the
sale and combining of sneakers the cost
of a pair of souped up digital sneakers
can already be measured in thousands of
dollars
but from what income are payments made
to the participants of the system the
first source of income is investors
money
investing in growing crypto projects is
now considered common courtesy
in the first months of its operation in
fact the project attracted 5 million
dollars from 16 investment funds the
second is advertising contracts
branded collections of sneakers have
already been released by asics
surely there will be other contracts
with manufacturers of sports equipment
the third is the commission for in-game
purchases so to speak it's six percent
and in just the last quarter of the last
year it turned over more than 26 million
dollars
now does this look like a pretty
convincing scheme to you
well that's the problem so let's quickly
go back to cryptokitties after their
first drop they managed to attract first
12 million dollars from investment funds
and then another 15 million dollars from
samsung but investment clearly doesn't
mean success
now these digital fluffy animals have
become part of internet history now
advertising budgets are all well and
good but would you advertise cat food to
the owners of digital animals
well it's the same situation here there
might be more and more participants
using step in to increase the price of
sneakers but it's unlikely that many of
them are real runners and finally
in-game payments this is a good and
steady source of income the creators of
roblox for example make money this way
now we've talked about this in detail in
one of our past videos so i won't go
over it again now
the problem is that according to forbes
only 2.3 million active participants are
currently registered in the system it
turns out that each of them brought the
system at least 11
now please note they didn't earn this
money on the contrary they brought it in
now here is the biggest difference with
roblox
most of the players go on roadblocks to
have fun and spend money
step in positions itself precisely as a
move to earn
and yet it turns out that the average
participant is still in the red in fact
even more than you think look at this
graph
the exchange rate of the main domestic
currency is falling rapidly
the simplest sneakers allow you to earn
1.7 gst per day that is about 20 cents
compare it with the peak when the same
sneakers could bring you 10 to 15
now let's go back to boston for a moment
in august 1919
a young and enterprising immigrant from
italy charles ponzi told his friends
about a win-win financial scheme
at the beginning of the century large
countries concluded an agreement that
you can buy ordinary postage stamps not
only for money but also exchange them
for a special coupon
you put such a coupon in an envelope to
the addressee in another country who
would then exchange the coupon for
stamps to send a reply
now this system worked fine before the
first world war
but when the european economy went into
decline a peculiar situation developed
in italy you could only get one stamp
for a coupon whereas in the us
you could get six at once
now ponzi offered to take advantage of
this situation to buy coupons
inexpensively
travel across the border and make a
profit of 50 in three months he didn't
have any money of his own so he gave his
friends an opportunity to finance this
venture
one of them agreed to invest 200 in the
company
and this is how the securities exchange
company appeared
news about the financial startup spread
all over the city and soon the company
was attracting 250 000 a day
however this story came to an end as
early as 1920. kwanzi's friend the one
who made the initial investment demanded
50 of the company's current income
through the court
now he lost the lawsuit but the ministry
of finance became interested in the huge
revenues this company was generating it
soon became clear that the way the ponzi
scheme worked was completely differently
to how it had been described ponzi
didn't buy any coupons in fact this
story was invented solely for
authenticity's sake
in fact the ponzi scheme paid dividends
to the old participants at the expense
of the new ones
a beautiful legend aggressive
advertising and a constant influx of new
users who dream of a return on their
investments
does it remind you of anything
now i'm sure none of you have missed the
news about bitcoin's dramatic fall from
grace
crucially the flagship cryptocurrency is
now dragging the entire crypto market
down to the bottom remember i mentioned
the board ape yacht club project
recently
the man who changed the modern world
made reference to it on techcrunch
bill gates the founder of microsoft and
one of the richest people in the world
used this nft as an example i don't know
i mean obviously expensive you know
digital images of monkeys are going to
improve the world immensely uh we all
agree on it and uh you know that's so
incredible now gates attributed the
success of the nft market as a whole to
the theory of the bigger fool
when the buyer of an overpriced asset
expects to sell it to someone who will
give even more now i wonder he'll be
right the creative windows or the
industry with a turnover of 22 billion
anyway we'll find out soon enough but
thanks for tuning in today guys this was
emily with some sub and i'll be waiting
for you on our next tour of the online
jungle
[Music]
you